out to the war in Ukraine Russia has
retaliated in brutal Fashion After drone
strikes on three of its airfields the
latest happened this morning at a
Russian airport just outside of Ukraine
at the same time Russian forces were
firing missiles at dozens of targets as
MTS Tire reports Russia has been trying
to demoralize ukrainians by knocking out
access to Power and Water
it was a frenzied attack on cities and
towns across Ukraine but moscow's
assault might have been far worse were
not for Ukrainian missile defense forces
shooting most of the missiles out of the
sky yes come back but that small comfort
for those who've paid the ultimate price
including olha trosina's two neighbors
they were seeing off their son and
daughter-in-law she says they went
outside to wave goodbye and they were
killed their house was also destroyed
Russia has ruthlessly been targeting
Ukraine's energy grid and is being
accused of weaponizing winter by
plunging huge parts of the country into
cold and darkness
in her song which was liberated from
Russia just three weeks ago volunteers
now have little choice but to cook meals
over open fires so that people have
something hot to eat
nine months of Russian occupation has
obliterated any semblance of a normal
life for people here but what ukrainians
have shown time and again
is that they'll do anything to help each
other
these energy workers are giving one of
the biggest Helping Hands by restoring
power lines despite the unexploded
ordinances that litter huge areas as
Moscow continues to make life a misery
across Ukraine President Vladimir Putin
made a rare public appearance cruising
in a Mercedes on the Crimean Bridge
now that's the very Bridge Ukraine
denies blowing up two months ago this
morning Ukraine is also denying being
responsible for those attacks deep
inside Russian territory only saying
that such incidences are and I'm quoting
here karma for Russia's Invasion Tony
interesting choice of words there MTS
Time Force and Kiev MTS thank you very
much